[Musique]
Je n'ai pas de maison,
pas de chaussures, pas d'argent,
pas de classe, pas d'amis,
pas d'école, pas de
mots,
pas de travail et non  l'argent
n'a pas de père n'a pas de mère
pas d'
argent pas d'air pas d'
enfants pas de rien pas de
vin pas de bébé non
[musique
] pas de monnaie pas de
jetons  Je n'ai pas d'amour,
je n'ai pas de pays et je n'ai rien,
je n'ai pas de dieu
mon âme
j'ai mon sexe
[Musique]
j'ai mes bras mes doigts mes jambes mes pieds
parfois j'ai des maux de tête
et des maux de dents et des mauvais moments aussi
comme toi
[Musique]
je suis sur mes cheveux ma tête
mon cerveau  mes oreilles mes yeux
mon nez et ma bouche j'ai mon sourire
j'ai ma langue mon menton mon cou
mes fous
[Musique]
ma
j'ai ma liberté dans mon cœur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi